Miguel on yacht area is dissatisfied his
snack bar is well situated it's in the
middle of the bus station in the Chilean
town of Santa Cruz but things are slow
this morning so Miguel tries to drum up
a little business
multicon who cos is a thirst quencher
that contains wheat so it's more of a
snap than a drink just take multi or
cooked Huss tweet add dried peaches and
top it off with a liquid in which the
peaches were cooked did you get that
pretty ain't it has to simmer for a good
amount of time really loud then it's
cooled and sweden's using not too much
sugar but it has to be sweet or
something would you like to try it
Miguel's been here for more than 30
years his snack cost the equivalent of
one euro 30 that's not cheap the average
monthly income in Chile is just over
nine hundred euros
but Miguel knows how he can attract
customers at the bus station with a
wheat drink or a portion of french fries
my sexy co-ed had to sacrifice a lot
that's the only way we were able to
succeed we're a perfectly ordinary
middle-class family but we have a lot of
energy if West saw me and it's thanks to
this beverage that my son and study at
university connector voluto customers at
last this couple is thirsty are they
hungry as well with multi conlou cos you
don't have to decide of course the lady
gets the first taste it's really
delicious made with natural ingredients
without additives besides it's the
national drink here in Chile the analogy
Miguel is already mixing the next batch
and hoping for more customers better
days are sure to come